what's going on guys this is rob and in
this video uh we're going to talk about
the all black necro sword which we've
discussed really indirectly during our
conversations with like gore and knoll
and all that kind of stuff uh but we're
going to dedicate a video to this
especially now because it's more
important than it's ever been now having
said that if you guys have been a
follower of this channel for a while you
probably know all this stuff so this
video is dedicated more for the people
who don't know this than anything else
and of course on geek culture explained
we'll also talk about how the all black
necrosword will likely lead into the
introduction of null in the marvel
cinematic universe so um philosophy guys
who are unfamiliar with this the all
black necro sword is really one of the
most powerful weapons that exist in
marvel comics and much like individuals
of immense power people like franklin
richards or the incredible hulk or
something along those lines you also
have artifacts right the infinity stones
or the infinity gauntlet or cosmic cube
or the casket of ancient winners or the
serpent crown you have these different
artifacts out there that depending on
who's writing them are immensely
powerful uh when it comes to the all
black necro sword the way it was
originally introduced in marvel comics
we didn't really have any kind of an
origin for it instead during jason
aaron's thor god of thunder run which
the first story arc is the one that
dealt with gore the god butcher that the
all black necro sword had just really
made its way to gore and the way this
played out is that gore you know kind of
reiterating this history a little bit
gore was initially a guy who just lived
on this world that was exceedingly harsh
and the people on that world were both
nomads as well as very very
strong in their convictions when it came
to the gods they worshipped the problem
with this is that the gods wouldn't
always quote unquote answer their prayer
right so some of them would starve to
death or different things along those
lines gore ended up losing his whole
family and in doing so basically cursed
the gods and then was kicked out of his
own tribe and the result of this is he
basically stumbled across two individual
gods one that was clad in black and one
that was clad in gold who would have
seemingly died in a battle with each
other and when gore saw this he realized
that gods existed which was the worst
thing that could have happened for gods
out there because what gore came to the
realization of is that if gods exist
then it means they were hearing the
prayers of the people who were praying
to them they simply just didn't care and
so because of that he essentially took
the sword that belonged to the to the
black god and then in turn went on a
rampage across the universe killing
every god he could find now what made
gore so cool wasn't necessarily the all
block but the motivation of gore himself
right the idea that he had done things
like torture the god of torture right it
was crazy some of the stuff that he had
done but the reality of this is the
sword itself had previously belonged to
a being named null now we'll talk about
that here in a second but as far as gore
goes his use of the all black if you go
back and you read the comic closely one
of the things you notice is he's
actually learning to use the sword as he
uses it that it's a lot more than simply
just a weapon capable of killing gods
and so that's why over time instead of
it all just sort of manifesting
immediately that over time gore starts
to learn that he can do things like
manifest these kind of uh these kind of
you know shadow creatures right
basically his henchmen those kind of
things right just sort of go forward
from there uh create these constructs
that can fight on his behalf in some
kind of a situation now because of both
gore's motivation and the power of the
all black this basically led him to a
point where in the future he had
essentially had something constructed
called the god bomb and what he intended
to do was use the god bomb to basically
detonate and destroy all gods across
time and space so in effect every god
that had ever currently does or will
ever exist would cease to be they would
be destroyed by the god bomb itself
thereby killing all gods in existence
across the entire history and the future
of the universe but for the all-black
necro sword itself in its conflicts
against thor there were some impressive
feats but it was really just kind of
given to us as this weapon that was
capable of both injuring and potentially
even killing thor and it's what made the
fights between thor and gore so
dangerous is because with gore basically
facing off against a wide array of
different gods he learned all different
kinds of fighting styles and he learned
all different methods of killing gods so
by the time he encountered thor gore was
pretty well seasoned in his ability to
kill beings of divine nature and so
again there wasn't a whole lot there
insofar as what we could see the sword
do but one thing that i do want to point
out is right off the bat and when i say
right off the bat i mean like the first
time that we ever saw gore wielding the
all-black necro sword in marvel comics i
mean you could look on forums everywhere
right internet posts twitter the whole
nine yards that people were like that
looks like a symbiote like literally
that sword looks like a symbiote like it
it moves the way you would expect a
symbiote to move it's black in the same
way that venom is it quite literally
looks like it's tied into a symbiote
itself and so what this did is it went
into donnie kate's run on venom and what
donnie cates did during this run
specifically the king and black
storyline is he introduced this
backstory and origin to the all black
necro sword that basically bookended
into jason aaron's thor god of thunder
and the gore storyline as well as how it
is that gore was even able to do the
things he was in the first place because
one of the big questions that people had
is how could a simple sword be so
powerful that it can just kill gods all
over the place where does this thing
come from what does it do and so over
the course of a handful of different
stories right the king and black you
know the the valkyries tie in and so on
and so forth what we basically learned
is that in what was called the yawning
void which is really just a really cool
name that basically means the time
between the end of the sixth universe
and the beginning of the seventh
universe that you saw being named null
come into existence now we don't
specifically know exactly how and a lot
of people really argue that null is
basically a facility of the cosmic
entity oblivion um and so as a result of
that it's just kind of a version right
like you know in the same way that jean
grey is like a facsimile of the phoenix
force to a degree kind of an avatar of
sorts um that when null came into
existence because nothing had been
created in the universe yet that quite
literally null just lived in this
eternal darkness which he loved right he
was emo he just sat around all day
smoking cigarettes listened to the cure
but in all seriousness uh null cherished
the void right this this kind of
primordial darkness as it's called in
marvel comics now the result of this is
that once the celestials began
essentially creating life in the
universe it was quite literally
intruding on the void of null and so in
response to this null waged war against
the celestials now during this time he
crafted the all-black necro sword as a
weapon that could be used to defeat the
celestials and in fact he actually cut
the head off of one of them now
ultimately of course he was defeated by
the celestials and pushed back into the
void but what this did at least
according to the valkyries tie-in for
the king and black storyline that with
the head of the celestial being severed
that null used the celestial's power to
both fuel his sword as well as provide a
kind of place whereby those individuals
who were killed by the necro sword would
basically be pushed through that
celestial it would feed on their energy
and of course they would be cast into
what was basically purgatory something
along those lines but the thing about
this is that this was the answer to the
question of why the sword was so
powerful now in order to book in to what
jason aaron had done with regards to
gore the god butcher that when null had
finally escaped the void yet again that
null had gone on a rampage and
essentially started doing what what gore
had been doing before gore did it that
quite literally nol was going around the
cosmos killing different gods his
rationale being that if he could destroy
the gods from across the cosmos that in
turn there would be no one to protect
these different segments of the universe
and he could incorporate them back into
the void until such a time as the amount
of primordial darkness he could control
would exceed the power of the celestials
and then he could destroy the celestials
that way and so literally going on a
crusade a conquest to kill as many gods
as he can while we didn't necessarily
know the details of it all we knew was
that somewhere along the line he had
ended up coming across what was an army
of golden gods of course he killed all
of them except for one and in venom vol
4 issue number four it was given to us
that null was the person who would fall
into the planet of gore and basically
been killed or at least a version of
himself being killed by that golden god
and then of course gore got his hands on
the all-black necro sword now in the
same issue and this is one of the
coolest things that in the same issue
because uh null could not be killed by
traditional means meaning he is by all
standards of measurement at least
spirit-wise immortal meaning his essence
would continue to live on that he was
actually fully aware of gore taking the
all-black necrosword and going on a
rampage to kill gods across the cosmos
despite the fact that gore's motivation
was different from nulls in the end the
act was still the same and so null
basically just let it happen right he
just didn't take the sword back because
in effect whether he intended to or not
gore was continuing the campaign of null
now during this time one of the things
that null had realized is that his
ability to craft the all-black necro
sword was only one facet of his power
that even when he existed in the void he
wasn't fully aware of what it was he
could do until light or until creation
was brought into the universe and
because shadow is basically just only
possible by virtue of the existence of
light null realized he could control
shadows he could quite literally control
living shadows and while the all black
necrosword was kind of an extension of
that the full totality of what null
could do in creating shadows came in the
form of him creating symbiotes and
that's where you got venom and all that
kind of stuff from and so ultimately of
course noel's rampage where he continued
yet again right going out into the
universe causing all kinds of problems
where that was ultimately ended by his
own symbiotes turning against him and
then imprisoning him inside of a world
of course he ended up escaping and
returning during the king and black
storyline where he was ultimately
defeated by eddie brock wielding the
unipower right the force of the or at
least the enigma force and so again the
nature of the all black necro sword it
kind of sum this up the all black necro
sword is quite literally a weapon that's
powered by the energy of a dead
celestial and so that's why the sword is
so powerful because it's literally using
the energy of a celestial to kill gods
and because celestials are some of the
most powerful beings in existence and
looking at older stories right like the
was it the third host when the
celestials confronted like odin and zeus
and all those guys and basically had all
the power in the world way more power
than any of the sky fathers had and
could have annihilated all of them that
was really the basis behind the power of
null and the all black necro sword in
saying that because it's powered by a
celestial it basically dwarfs the power
of gods meaning the sword can kill gods
and that's why it is that gore was able
to use the all black necro sword to kill
gods because it's an extension of the
power of null himself and so if you guys
are interested in getting uh more of the
finer details regardless you know
regarding how all this stuff happened
make sure you guys check out the
playlist i've i've created a new
playlist that basically focuses
explicitly on the all-black necro sword
so basically thor god of thunder the god
butcher storyline the return of gore and
then the king in black which should
basically give you everything you need
to know about the uh the the all black
necro sword beyond what we've talked
about here right some of the some of the
finer details the more nuanced things
but in effect yeah the all black necro
sword is a wildly powerful weapon how
that translates to the movies i'm not
entirely sure that's something that
we'll talk about over a geek culture
explained at any rate this video should
give you a pretty good understanding of
how the all black necrosword came into
existence and why it's so powerful and
how it's been used so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you